[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Now, the term
psychedelic is usually
associated with
mind-expanding chemicals,
consciousness-expanding
drugs that grow on the earth.
But the root of the
word psychedelic
actually means to make
manifest the mind.
Now, you can see why psychedelic
substances bring our visions
into being.
We call it active
hallucinations.
But is this not, in many
ways, the same thing
as our imagination?
And is technology not, in
many ways, a manifestation
of the human mind,
embodied imagination,
the actualization, the
rendering of our hallucinations
into existence?
You know, the creature
that ate the mushrooms
and then started
doing art on the caves
is the same species that
hallucinated starships
into existence.
Technology is
literally psychedelic.
It literally is
outsourced cognition
and how we extend the
boundaries of the human mind.
The goals of mind expansion,
the counterculture 1960s
ethos of expand your horizons,
transcend your reality,
make that cognitive
leap is no different
than the manifestation of
our information technology.
Google is the first
psychedelically informed
super power.
Its visions of
inter-connectivity,
inter-conductivity
and repository
of all of human knowledge
becomes almost like Gaea,
like a collective consciousness.
So again, the whole notion
is that we should really
come to understand that the
whole psychedelic revolution
from the '60s ended up being
literalized by the information
technologies that
have transformed
our world over
the last 30 years.
[MUSIC PLAYING]